[Music]
so yesterday we don't one of the worst
days of my life
since we have no running water I had to
go and fetch water down by the creek
which is far away and down a ravine
filled a bucket of water up she loved it
she's acting like it's not a good thing
she was smiling the whole time she loved
it and then we have look now I did not
love it we have this floor we have a
place we can do it Jay in the middle of
the woods we just have one more piece to
nail off and then then it's on to the
walls
oh yeah Wesley came today over there
Wesley dauphinois
he's my buddy we both grew up on the
East Coast not very far from each other
we became best friends and now he's
helping us build this cabin one reason
I'm extra excited wes is here is because
normally I have the grunt work of
hauling the lumber and that we need for
the build Oh what stood it today thank
you Wesley's looking like Arnold
[Music]
it feels like you're firing it done it's
not bad thing that's a hexagon baby I
feel like I'm in Legend of Zelda
[Music]
look at the lights look at the way they
didn't down so the generator ran out of
gas but we're not freaking out cuz
things happen I'm totally calm
you know Wesley's only here for tonight
we have to get the ribs up today so that
means we're gonna have to come back and
do it in the dark
that's okay it's okay I'm gonna breathe
she's probably gonna make us stop and go
do a bunch of other things like a
30-mile drive into town yeah
tone is really far so we might as well
get other things it makes sense let's go
come on do it you like it you do hahaha
we're back on schedule kind of meaning
we're working as hard as we can into the
night like Wes was saying this is like
tradition to have the lights set up and
be working out here it's pretty cool I
tried to tell them it's no big deal
we'll just set up some lights and work
in the dark and look it was okay now I'm
feeling real good we're gonna work for
the next couple hours we're gonna at
least get all of these wall trusses
that's what we've been calling them or
what is it west wall rushes wall trusses
we begin those built up and so we're
gonna get all six of them ready and yeah
I think it would be cool if we get them
up tonight and it's kind of darkened in
the morning get to walk out and really
see what it looks not very smart to do
it that way because you can't look at
what you're doing but yeah the Creator
in me wants to do it right now are these
gonna be like this yes ma'am Wow yeah
babe it's on it
what are they attached let me get this
straight see Mary this goes like this
and then these long guys attached to it
do we have a ladder tall enough how do
we attach it Wesley's just gonna jump up
there that's why we brought him along
because of his ups it's over eight feet
really two inches whoa all right you're
good
of this checking we're gonna attach to
laying down flat on the deck and then I
think we'll be able to attach a third
one and just Teeter it up Wes can you
hold can you lift it up higher like
above your head there you go buddy
yeah really glad you came too there was
one more screw it now we're gonna try it
I'm scared Gary let's walk yours down
okay okay we're doing it shut up
no no no keep going can you put yours
down Wes go on to Sarah's in wet go
under stairs go on to Sarah's and pull
it back she's gonna lose it go under
stairs now Wes let go yours okay yours
is pointing the wrong way it you have to
pick it up and move it okay we need to
lift it up vertically so mine is
supposed to go where right here right
where you are we have to lift it up oh
I'm so scared
one two okay and lift straight up take a
step just slow slow slow
I'm in the race smart right yeah that
thing's about to pop that thing is gonna
pop out hold on hold on hold on wait
just wait you guys wait don't move just
told you
I don't think you understand how close
that is to breaking and if that breaks
what god damn it's cuz it was those
screws run didn't catch enough do you
have a ladder tall enough to I bet you
that thing doesn't even go anywhere near
where it needs to be okay baby you hold
this oh you're not gonna put a ladder on
a ladder yeah stand right here and hold
this like this Wes get that extension up
in this you drop that that can literally
go through my head I won't oh my god
alright how do you feel
please be careful what you're going up
there I don't want to die with the drill
in my head
nice oh my god you got to be kidding me
mine
this is cooler let's do it let's put the
other ones up this is ridiculous dude
all right ready this should be 30
degrees psycho geometry loving it I'm
admiring it super glad they're having
fun I'm freaking out
I'm feeling better everyone we get up
there now now it's not just all wobbly
every piece now is just gonna make it
stronger and stronger yeah no no so far
so good
feels crazy this thing is insane it
looks like one of those things that
reaches down and gets a price and hit
when you go to the bowling alley totally
I mean get your prize Sun just imagine
once if these things go in and these
walls go in and this is all sheets yeah
this is this is crazy I can't believe we
stood this up I know I can't believe we
did it when we I was like no I couldn't
have done it without y'all obviously and
I appreciate everyone stick-to-itiveness
like just doing it through the night
sweet that's a wrap folks I want to step
back and look at it it looks like a UFO
like landed here
oh yeah yeah nice that's sick that's
gonna be awesome it's just like one of
the coolest things I've ever seen please
be sure to LIKE and subscribe this
channel so you never miss an update and
please back us on patreon so we can keep
these free videos coming yes free eight
free we need you back us please